welcome to this special edition of
Hannity the Trump agenda
I'm Jeanine Pirro in tonight for Shawn
President Trump they're wrapping up his
speech at a make America great again
rally in Pensacola Florida joining us
with reaction
our American Conservative Union chairman
Matz slap former special assistant to
President Trump and former press
secretary for Vice President Mike Pence
Mark Lauder and Republican strategist
Noel Nick pork all right I got to tell
you every time I listen to the president
speak and get those audiences fired up I
say to myself there is no one better
than the president then Donald Trump
with an audience I mean we were that the
cheering and the sense of Americanism is
it's infectious Matt what do you think
yeah it's electric and I think you know
Donald Trump is doing something very
important that president sometimes
failed to do he's getting out of the
bubble he's piercing the bubble he's
going out there and and and talking to
real Americans he's feeding off the
crowd it's electric and I think it
really gives him energy and I think it's
really important for a leader to go
around the country and tell him what he
wants to do and my gosh he didn't leave
anything on the table judge well and
it's clear a mark that that that matters
correct he hit every note whether it was
the you know sanctuary cities the second
amendment religious freedom by American
what's your take from this speech two
things one he's doing exactly what he
said he was going to do on the campaign
trail and two every time you see the
fake news about how he's not having a
good time in the White House trust me
this man loves being president of the
United States and taking it in the
direction to make America great again I
saw it tonight without a doubt and no
well what do you take away from tonight
you know what judge Jeanine America
needed this tonight America needed this
speech I was about to jump through the
camera when I was listening to this I
was so proud to be an American and he
puts America first and we needed this
right now with all
the division between the parties between
the GOP and then another thing is he
just listed why he is the champion he's
the mascot for the middle class for the
working American I mean this is such
passion and you know he loves this that
he's not reading off teleprompters this
is his heart this is who he is and this
is why he ran for the presidency and
look at the markets that you know that
are enjoying the the ride of a good
economy we're back on track and America
felt it tonight and you know and and
I'll go back to you Matt you know one of
the things he talked about which was you
know one of the more interesting points
is when he talked about the fake news
media I thought he said you know maybe
with a drop in the 350 points when Brian
Ross came out with that some would say
inaccurate or fake news some might say a
lie about the Mike Flint possibly
testifying against the the president he
said you know what they ought to sue ABC
that was a shocker do you think that was
an ad liver you think that what was in
his speech a class-action lawsuit for
their for their losses in their 401ks
you know I think what you see at the end
there is he comes back to the themes
that he ran on and you hear the cadence
of those familiar lines but in the
middle of it judge it's all coming from
Trump's heart
yeah it's spontaneous it's what he feels
it's coming right out and I do think he
has a grievance with the media judge he
was not talking about you by the way he
he he
we've been concerned has been trying to
prosecute this case against the
left-wing left-leaning media for decades
after decades for generations and he
comes in with this concept of fake news
and I think the American people really
realize they don't want to hear it
anymore and you know what I mean he
opened everyone's eyes every in the
beginning he thought mark you know maybe
you know this fake news that's
ridiculous but I think people are
understanding it really is fake news
that there is stuff that isn't accurate
that is outright lies but mark you know
one of the things that he said that I
wasn't aware of the president said that
black home ownership is the highest that
it's ever been in the history of this
country you think anybody would give him
credit for this and did you even know
this mark yeah I did not know it until
we heard him saying tonight and but when
you look at the economic record of this
president it is so remarkable we had the
new numbers come out today I mean
manufacturing Obama was losing a
thousand jobs a month in his final year
this president added 16,000
manufacturing jobs a month he said he
was going to rebuild American
manufacturing he's doing it so so many
of these things you're not going to hear
unless the president gets out there and
says it himself and that's what you saw
tonight on full display and and finally
you know know well when he said
something interesting he talked about
seven trillion dollars that we have
spent in the Middle East he said you
know we could rebuild the infrastructure
of this country three times over what do
you think he was saying I mean I think
yeah I think he was telling Americans
look how much waste is out there look
look at what we're doing this is why a
businessman this is why his leadership
under his leadership we've had massive
job creation we have a rallying stop
market we have basically making America
great again I know that sounds
oversimplifying things but that's
exactly his message and that's what's
happening and anyone that says oh
whatever Donald Trump's not doing
anything look at the numbers I mean the
economy is not lying the fact that
people have money in their pocket it's
not lying well and and the prediction is
much more anyway I want to thank all
three of you for joining us